[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
we talk about whatever we want we have
Mike here today
lissa he's an outdoor she's a youtuber
thespia he got scared he got TV shows or
movies or things have we seen you in I
was in Maze Runner I was in Grey's
Anatomy oh sit well I'm a doctor
how'd you get away murder yeah what were
you I'm like in Maze Runner I was a
doctor Maze Runner no I was a doctor
doctor doctor doctor accounting
accounting so yeah I mean my my Asian
parents proud because in how to get it
with murder I was a law intern and then
in Grey's Anatomy I was an army doctor
no a doctor or lawyer might pretend by
pretend so cool the Grizz now he was fun
though because it was actually like a
flashback army episode so it was yeah it
was like we were in an army show damn so
this sounds like it was a little bit of
there was a little bit of pain in that
statement about making Asian parents
proud did that pain too if you fail you
felt that pain were you were how do they
take your acting career choice so I
should so there was not there's not as
much pain as I'm as I'm finding my other
friends have to let it out ya know my
parents were third generation actually
born in America so so they're white yeah
they only had a little bit of that
disapproval it wasn't like that
full-blown like you're gonna destroy the
family by doing this [ __ ] their parents
disapproved of them yeah however I'm
coming to find it's more of like a
multi-layered disapproval because the
first disapproval is like oh we don't
know it acting is don't do it but
they're American but they're American
they know people who have done it and
they're like we have actual evidence
okay our friend tried to go into movies
and look at them now you know so we
actually have evidence you want to be
like that you know
like they filled and they're like you
want to fail and yeah we're like yeah
like how hard it was clearly for this so
they're actually using logic versus the
first generation parents are just gonna
be like now you're gonna be a homeless
person right and then the second
generation maybe they'll be like I don't
think it's safe and in the surgeon or
third generation is like don't use logic
and they'll be American about it yeah
exactly that's [ __ ] up so you got a
debate them yeah yeah but I think I
think luckily at the end of the day
they're kind of like artists to their
artistic like my mom comes from like a
artistic painting like family oh and my
dad went to school for like broadcast
stuff they don't do artistic stuff for
their actual job now but when I brought
it up to him they were kind of like you
know we've been there we we know the
urge i any failed that's why they're
scared that you'll fail yeah that's so
just like me I think they're fears on
you dude you're like did you know mommy
wanted to be a [ __ ] painter but she
sucked yeah and then that's why I'm just
kidding yeah it's not right for sure
like means yeah she they didn't like I
guess yeah become ultimately right yeah
and the arts they they did the what's it
called the cop out she was helping the
cop no they did the safe ride safe route
yeah the safe route oh my my dad is an
MRI manager so kind of turned this is
imaging like camera stuff into Oh
through like medical field he's the only
one that has to get the perfect angle
and like a perfect in the machine like a
silhouette of a bone and do it we can't
see what
this your dad were a LED best all day
long no that's x-rays so MRI now he used
to be an x-ray tech now if any of human
MRI tech have a lead vest yeah you
shouldn't wear don't they put the people
in that [ __ ] machine like a
sarcophagus [ __ ] yeah and it's like no
it's loud yeah
did it like a race which one's the one
where it's like a it's not a cuz I
didn't go into like a coffee
cat-scan it was a it was like a circle
thing right yeah no like it wasn't like
a tube that I went through was like a
circle that went past me like that [ __ ]
yeah like my blood [ __ ] oh no morphine
no I was in more feet
well they did give me more medicine feta
means I don't know but that's when I
discovered I don't know why people like
morphine cuz they did give you morphine
that time after my surgery and like
doesn't it feel bomb no it made my
entire body tense up so bad that I got
cramps in my back and I was like why the
[ __ ] do people like this relax they're
the wrong way I don't know I hated it
because some war movies right it's
always like getting more feet blown off
oh this feels kinda good yeah that's the
problem
maybe try it again when wore off yeah
and I was just like I'm good with the
pain I don't wanna do that again
vicodin I don't know why people like it
so much it made me just throw up
violently yeah I just I think it's just
some really sensitive to toxins like I'm
super light way with alcohol and all
that and so they said that like 1 out of
10 females like have that reaction so it
was just not a good time for me I took
vicodin - I liked it it just felt like
floating away it just felt like I was on
a boat and I was just like getting towed
and I just like yeah non-stop not above
when you took like yeah
might have been it oh that was a
seasickness oh my god rather take the
pain
oh that was my it was for my wisdom
teeth I know like I'd rather take the
paymon dunno went on the auditions was
it like you and then 12 other guys that
look exactly like you all were in doctor
timeout oh no racist they don't all look
the same they do honestly I've only been
on a few auditions in my life yeah they
do have a certain look they're looking
at when I when I read the part I was
like okay cool
I kind of know how to dress when I got
there it was me and then like 12 other
people but then I was gonna audition for
this gay character yeah there was just
12 dudes that looked like me but they
all look a little bit gayer now and some
of them were actually gay love core I
think they thought this probably got the
part but it was just it's just weird
sitting like when you look at it like oh
[ __ ] she's like a pepper factory almost
where you really want to nail this part
but I'm so [ __ ] replaceable yeah yeah
Darren's do that scene from all and what
she's gonna say auditioning I know
everyone has like the same shirt same
hair like one was like way harder is
that what it's like
I think I think when it when I first
started out um you know being an Asian
actor this so few Asian roles in general
right yeah back when I first started so
and a few Asian roles that were there
were very like stereotypical Asian roles
liquor store owner uh oh no I liked like
the young ones like they're like the IT
guy or like the nerd kid yeah um you get
good roles we get the cholos and the
teen moms Gardner the good would there's
a good TV show and just like all those
like sterotypical roles there should be
a dope TV show yeah I mean there's a lot
of TV shows actually with that that's
why they're there but like the main
characters I'll be partying past what
mate is the main kind and they're not
really like that or maybe like it's an
actor's story of being playing those
rules is it that yeah is the lead
occupation so you know that Walter White
he's a chemist I see it be a lawnmower
dude yeah
a la lon
the gardener is his main job that'd be
interesting yeah and then his wife is a
maid yeah that's what and they come home
and like I had to mow so many lawns and
she's like I had it does never seen no
realize cuz they are though with main
honey are the main ones like the
light-skinned european-looking one do
they have another jobs or the rich ones
yeah in this show there's not a real
Mexican story that yes a gardener and a
maid husband-and-wife team yeah and they
always have the really hot daughter
who's super humble issues even know how
hot she is and then the rich could be
light-skinned guy sees her and he's like
whoa and then he's the OL she has a nice
booty huh and a nice rack but like she's
humble so you don't really see the rack
until he finally like until this one day
see it's like the pointing no bro that's
a [ __ ] POG and then the family starts
accepting her because she's got a lot of
class or the ex-girlfriend is trying to
like bring that [ __ ] down because she's
too bad do you ever know that every
woman that sounds like a king just his
Prince just saw like some [ __ ] peasant
girl and then picks her up and makes her
royal like that's like the same story
every single every single one though you
watch oh my god so how long have you
been acting I've been acting since 20
2010 I believe wow that's a long time
yeah that's when I got my first manager
do you like auditioning because I
[ __ ] hate it me too that's why that's
why I don't even audition audition twice
that's it
both times like that's it and then the
first one wasn't even audition it was a
pretend audition for my acting school
cuz everyone's literally dislike
Oh what do you care what can you do I
was like I did my op monologue and I was
like you know what [ __ ] you and [ __ ] you
because you don't know anything about
talent [ __ ] and then I was like oh even
though this is like a pretending like I
still it still gave me a lot of
nervousness because I don't like that
[ __ ] you know why I rather make my own
stuff no I just think it's tough
additions I don't why okay JK
we're like we got it I'm not gonna get
roles yeah that I want I want to be
Asian mom no one's gonna hire me for
Asian mom I want a respectable role you
know like like a asian grandpa that
likes to pick his nose and [ __ ] yeah yes
and it's doing well obviously so you
want not anymore because we stopped
doing that I got bored a lot of
youtubers thanks though thanks for
trying to compliment awesome no yeah I
just think like is it it's totally it's
a flawed process right because that's
not how it is on set no it's not at all
like it is on set it's just like that's
why I [ __ ] hated it because it's like
you're still doing it right no this
actually I've done it since I was eight
years old and this was like the first
year that I was like I don't wanna
audition anymore I'm so I don't want it
anymore it takes so much time out of
your day and so if you're trying to do
your own productions and then you have
to cancel last minute because you got a
series regular audition that's nine
pages long you got to prepare it and you
got to work with the acting coach it's
like I can't build anything because I'm
constantly leaving it to go to auditions
that's why we're gonna make it with
crypto and then fund our own films and
I'll support yours film you can have him
okay that's cool we're gonna hire all of
each other yeah and no one's gonna
disapprove of each other I don't care
how bad your guys's acting is it's gonna
be great you still go to those auditions
where it's like 12 people the same where
your manager has enough clout now or
you've done enough work where it's like
there's like less people and it's not
just a roomful of it look-alikes yeah so
actually since when I was talking with
those stereotypical roles things have
actually been getting better and better
yeah so now it's not like I go to only
roles that are like oh only this Asian
guy that looks like now it's like this
gay guy all right it's like oh it's
Ryder or like a guy that likes I don't
know like actually useful yeah actually
be a person and not just like some damn
ride horses do yeah man no no yeah it's
it's it's it's not necessarily like I
guess only Asian it's like it's it's a
bunch of different uh what's been your
favorite role that you've auditioned for
so this one role that I got was for this
series where it was really cool because
it was it was his high school series
like kind of like Degrassi meets
Riverdale but I was auditioning for the
youhad guy that goes to the school oh
I'll be the hot guy right and then and
then after we did it I'm super fun like
the first day was there's like oh hi
nice my love is just nice to meet you
make up make up make up
so uh how long you've been acting you
make up make up make up really quickly
audition no no the first day on set so
your lines isn't even lines it's like
make out the first day was like yeah but
when you're in auditions because that
reminds me this is the one part that I
never learned how to do is if it says
and then they kiss what are you doing
that part sometimes I brushed over it
and like not done the kiss part
sometimes are like can you go back and
do the kiss and then one time I had an
acting coach I was like just blow a kiss
and then they hated that what do you do
they're supposed to kiss there's nobody
there to kiss you just miss like do we
make out for a while and then goes wait
I'm not ready or whatever like I'm
making out with the air like oh you grab
one of the people that's auditioning you
and you kiss that for those I don't I
think you just like you like kiss with
your eyes I guess you kind of like nips
however I mean depending on like the
type of kiss right so it's like you just
said sure I didn't know you did know the
scene and then you like if it's a loving
kiss you just like you know like you
know no no no you don't like tender kiss
me it's like you you did it and then
like MOOC like you're you are you going
to the state after it would have
happened it was like it was like say the
scene begins like right after like so
now we're gonna you know or you blush or
something yeah oh I felt that it those
butterflies yeah in your brain yeah but
but but anyway that that role is really
cool because they're after washing it
there's like a litter is seen where
they're talking about the hot guy like
the high school kids and then they're
turns and reveal me and then like
watching it I was like wait this is the
first time I've ever seen
high school kids talking about the hot
the hot guy and like it's the asian guy
but they do feel like molesky because
you were not in high school I mean it's
like cheap TV high school you know like
like you are the only adult and all your
cast members are kids the whole time I
was thinking is it illegal if your cast
mates are underage and you have to do a
kissing scene with them dude what about
suck the titty on Game of Thrones like I
think about that well it's obviously a
15-second ode actresses - well do you
know I just join a hails debut for four
hit well when I first saw him his whole
role was just sucking on a titty the
homo yeah yeah my favorite movie back in
the day I love Nick Swardson I was like
man what a great role the whole thing he
was like 16 you're just sucking on a
titty like so he's the younger well it
was a hot girl at the party that's a
good movie y'all should watch it I was
singing about that because I just
started watching the show pen15 have you
on Hulu it's good because it's like Maya
what your name is on it she's a half
Japanese actor so it deals a lot of like
Japanese American issues oh cool
but um it takes place Japanese yeah she
plays full Japanese in it but she it
takes place in year 2000 so they're all
middle school so the two main characters
are actually adults playing middle
schoolers but all the other kids are
actual kids so I was thinking about that
show man that's what just song here's my
buddy yeah so I was thinking about that
I was like wait if they never have like
um like a love story
like are they allowed to kiss each other
you know cos oh yeah it's weird it's a
good show though like it's acting its
art like there's not real you know it's
like 17 year olds that had to kiss like
actual like mid-20s dude but then I
think the parents have to sign off on it
okay gosh I feel weird as a kid or Pat
both well as a kid I feel rewarded
something I also recently realized I'm a
huge anime nerd so like home one of my
dreams is like to make I got a
live-action like Sailor Moon movie I
think oh I'll be dull but someone
pointed out like wait Prince Terrien
like Tuxedo Mask
he was in college yeah and Serena and
the girls they're in high school and
they're dating I was like that's a lot
of stations okay in Japan that's what I
mean
statutory statutory love I think I'm
making it out okay so here's the thing
that people will not really quite
understand because it's hella taboo in
America but okay out here like the prime
of a woman is like I don't know like the
new 20s or something like that it's a
woman right like yeah yeah but like you
know she looks like a woman right like
yeah it doesn't matter what age you are
what you look like right cuz there's
some 20 year olds that look 50
but yeah so they look like women right
but out there the prime of a girl is in
high school so everyone looks at them
like all [ __ ] are so high that's
[ __ ] weird
due to the states ha ass Korean girl in
a vietnam when I was doing this Malibu
brand deal thing and she was hot as [ __ ]
this hot Korean lady and I guess she was
a model but she's like I don't do it
anywhere I'm like oh my god why don't
you do it oh yeah she said she's too old
to spike 27 and she's like yeah I'm too
old I'm too fat she was listed Wow
stands around like this yeah I'm too fat
yeah all these balls you look like
flawless
I think worldwide they stop at like 20
years yeah you could still do like
Victoria's Secret models or like you
know but I don't know she just in her
own head was like I'm mad hi old I'm too
ugly and I'm like what am i maybe she's
like you don't count because you're not
one of us yeah that would have [ __ ]
killed me really ah yeah cuz that's like
it's so funny when they say that like
don't you know that there's other pee
around you and you're sitting here
complaining yeah it's like that's [ __ ]
up so your skin's really nice you have a
skin regimen just happen yeah I I have
to brag I have heard this a lot thank
you people have asked but and people
would say this answer I don't do
anything
will you just use soap and water or just
water I mean wash your face in the
shower
you got good genetics yeah but that's
the thing like that's the half-korean to
me like I'm always hot so I'm always
like like I'm on set zero people always
like patting me down you're half Korean
and half granny I thought you were like
Chinese I'm half Chinese also I was half
right you're half right
cuz almost half thinking you might be
Korean right cuz you're hot you should
have Chinese and then have creative oh
oh that's true cuz I was confused I was
like oh should I call them Chinese or
Korean Chinese chorizo trying to paint
the I'll still stuck on your parents and
I was like okay third generation right I
was like old school Asians typically
it's either Japanese or Chinese like
they just been here at the longest oh
yeah huh corney's yeah and then I'm like
okay well cuz Koreans they basically
came to the States after the 50s so I'm
like third generation hmm do you ever
feel unaccepted by either side not so I
think it's more maybe like Asian and
asian-american stuff cuz I was raised
pretty white yeah so I definitely shoes
off wasn't like mandatory in my house
things like that so definitely like
moving in here in LA you know a lot of
them I'm from New York
um but I feel like there's a lot of a
lot ages in New York too but a lot a lot
of Asians in LA that I'd become friends
with so it's definitely I've definitely
got a lot of comments of oh it's so
white like why would you like like what
did you just say I love you to your
parents well like that's weird
like so things like that I think versus
Korean I haven't I haven't really gotten
like oh you don't belong to this Korean
area
you know blowing this Chinese me I don't
and you know my parents yeah third
generation is pretty at that point if
you if you speak it you had to really
try hard yeah it's a it was messed up
because my on my Korean side they told
in the 70s they told my my my Korean
grandparents not to teach it to their
kids who said it would confuse them
which is the opposite of the truth right
aboot that happened to a lot of that's
what a lot of Asians don't understand
those like Asians in the 50s yeah is
they tried their best to Americanize
yeah they did something right what to
teach their kids that because they don't
want their kids to be looked upon as for
yeah yes my grandparents did came over
and they my grandma can barely speak
English like you can't even tell she's
speaking English but she won't speak
Tagalog in front of her kids because she
wanted them to be Americanized so then
when people are like how come you're so
uncultured any like don't know Tagalog
I'm like because my grandma wanted
everyone to be American like that was
like Wally he-man you don't even knows
yeah for sure you have my to my Chinese
grandfather like he was really bought
it's like the whole American Dream like
two kids get the baseball game yeah
western suits and when his Chinese
restaurant the Chinese restaurant
actually like was like all like cheeky
themed it was very like not China even
though those Chinese food was like very
like Oh for Americans and yeah so that's
cool I'm trying to learn Mandarin now
cuz I know you know have to make your
American dude [ __ ] that [ __ ] as an actor
an actor yeah then I let you do it yeah
yeah and now I
it's the kind of sucks as I remember
growing up at auditions and stuff when
people would be like oh can you like do
you know kung fu and I'd be like no I do
not yeah I'm defying the stare that but
now I'm like that's such it's so
[ __ ] that I had that yeah I was
brought to even think that I never got
that once I was like I should no [ __ ]
karate why don't I know it yet but now
I'm going to come through now so like
I'm gonna come on man I'm trying to like
get all that you know this is suck in
your race cuz for me they're always like
do you speak Spanish latina
well you need to learn Spanish every
agents but like you need to learn
Spanish I'm like
so many like Latinas here other actors
that speak fluent Spanish I'm gonna be
up against them that's a funny actually
did you ever want to like learn but then
I was like no but now I'm like dammit
why don't our Spanish is so helpful
[Music]
[Music]